يمكن أن يساعد اختراق طبي محتمل في
يوم من الأيام في تخفيف النقص في أعضاء المتبرعين
وقد نجح الجراحون في
زرع كلية خنزير دون
رفض من قبل الجهاز المناعي للمريض
الآن المتلقي كان مريضًا ميتًا دماغياً وقد
وافقت الأسرة قبل
إجراء الحفل وتم
إخراجها من الحياة  دعم الآن ،
تم توصيل الكلية الجديدة بأوعيتها الدموية
وتم الحفاظ عليها خارج جسدها لمدة 54
ساعة ،
لذا فإن ما فعلناه أساسًا هو أننا
زرعنا كلية
من خنزير معدل وراثيًا
يحتوي
على
الجزيء الرئيسي الذي
هو الذي يحدد حقًا عدم
توافق  العضو الذي تعرفه بين
خنزير وإنسان خرج
لينضم إلينا الآن من بالتيمور ميريلاند
هو دكتور دوريس مرة أخرى أستاذ جراحة زرع الأعضاء
بجامعة جونز
هوبكنز دكتور سيجيف لم يشارك في هذا البحث
ولكن عمليات زرع الكلى على وجه الخصوص هي
إحدى تخصصاته لذلك
شكرًا لكونك معنا
رائعًا ، نعم سعيدًا للدردشة حول هذا
السابق حقًا  نقلاً عن الاكتشاف ، إنه يوم عظيم
لأنه من الواضح أن هذا لم يكن
كليًا لخنزير عادي.
أنت تعلم أنه تم
زرع هذا العضو على مقياس التطور ،
كان هناك هذا النوع من
الرفض الفوري للعضو في غضون دقائق
إلى ساعات
وأم
بسبب الثورة في
الهندسة الوراثية للحيوانات
التي تعلم أن لدينا أملنا الأول في أن
نتمكن من تجاوز ذلك الأولي  الحاجز
والرائع حقًا في
هذا هو أنهم تمكنوا من
إخراج الجين الذي يلعب دورًا في
إنتاج الكربوهيدرات التي تحفز
جهاز المناعة البشري لرفض
الكلى والقدرة على العثور على مفتاح الإيقاف الجيني
أو إزالته.  أمر لا يصدق في
حد ذاته لأنه حدث يمكن للكلية أن
تعمل ولكن أيضًا ما مدى أهمية
أنها بدأت في فعل ما تفعله الكلى على
الفور تقريبًا ،
نعم أعني واحدًا  إذا كان القلق الأكبر
هو
عندما تفعل شيئًا كهذا
لأول مرة في الإنسان ،
فهناك كل أنواع الكوارث التي
يمكن أن تحدث ولا يبدو أن أيًا منها
يحدث في الواقع ،
فإن فورية وظيفة هذه
الكلى تبدو أشبه بزرع متبرع حي
أكثر من أي نوع آخر من
عمليات الزرع حيث تبدأ الكلى
على الفور في إنتاج البول على
الفور ولا تتفاعل حقًا
مع جهاز المناعة ، لذلك يعد هذا
أحد الأسئلة المثيرة للغاية هنا على
الرغم من إلى متى ستستمر هذه الكلية
في العمل أه تمت مراقبتها
لمدة 54  ساعات مع عدم وجود علامة على الرفض ،
فلماذا لا تراقب لفترة أطول ،
لذلك كان هذا سيناريو فريدًا مثيرًا للاهتمام
حيث
تم وضعه في
شخص متوفى
حتى لو كانت هناك كارثة
فلن تؤثر على المريض وبالتالي
لم يكن هناك سوى  نافذة قصيرة
أخلاقياً من الناحية البيولوجية حيث يمكنهم
مراقبة هذه الكلية من الواضح أن
الخطوات التالية هي الاستمرار في إجراء هذا النوع
من التجارب وفي النهاية وضع
هؤلاء الأشخاص الأحياء حيث من
الواضح أنه يمكنك مشاهدة العضو لفترة أطول